Vergleicht das gerade mal. Ja, der andere Chat, der alte Chat ist schon ein bisschen besser lesbar, finde ich, oder findet ihr nicht auch?
Jetzt noch ein bisschen Transparenz.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ne, so geht das nicht.
Filter.
Filter, Effekt.
Boah, alter, wie funktioniert das?
Wie macht man Transparenz? Okay, da brauche ich mal ein Guide gucken.
Und einen Keksrahmen drumherum.
OBS Transparency.
Transparency. Filter, Color Correction.
Naja, aber, haha.
Am besten wäre, man könnte nur den Hintergrund...
So ist doch auch doof, oder? Oder wie ist das so? Ein bisschen, ein bisschen transparent. Doch, so ist doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich glaube, so ist ganz gut.
Ne, das erkennt man nicht richtig. Ich sehe es gerade in der Vorschau, das erkennt man nicht richtig, das zackt.
Da muss ich mir was anderes ausdenken. Kann FFZ vielleicht
Opacity?
Transparent, guck mal mal, Theme.
Ah, guck mal da.
Opacity. Hier, hier kann man Transparency auswählen, Theme, Background.
Ah ne, man kann, man kann nicht einfach, man kann nicht einfach Alpha-Value eingeben.
Transparent Colors are not allowed.
Okay.
Ja, dann nicht.
Ach komm, Leute, wisst ihr was? Bevor ich jetzt hier noch ewig rummache, wir lassen heute mal den alten Chat genug. Ich überlege mir da irgendwas für.
Brauche hier auch noch die Vorschau. Aber gut zu wissen, dass es prinzipiell mit dem Browser funktioniert.
So, also.
Was zur...
Hast du Chat-GPT gesagt, sie sollen eine Copy-Pasta schreiben?
Das ist Streamlabs Chat-Overlay, was ich benutze.
Aber ich habe es schon seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr konfiguriert. Vielleicht muss ich es einfach noch mal neu konfigurieren, dass es eben
die neuen Emotes kann. Also, ich habe von Fußball keinen Plan, ist mir vollkommen egal.
Alles Graz.
GG. Das brauche ich zum Virtualisieren.
Vor allem bei Workstation. Hab ich. Okay. Leute, soll ich euch mal was, was, was, was Sättge, was Sättge erzählen?
Sättge-Time. Wann Code-Review mit Rust?
Hört mir auf mit dem Rust-Kram, Alter. Ich werde hier nix rewriten in Rust und wir werden auch nix in Rust machen.
Also, nein. Nein, nein, nein. Der Katze geht's gut. Sättge. Ich erzähle euch, was Sättge ist.
Ich habe keinen Bock, Frontend-Zeug zu basteln mehr.
Mir ist irgendwie die Lust drauf vergangen, gerade. Dann Backend-Rewrite.
Leute, ihr macht das falsch. Ihr macht das falsch.
Eigentlich hättet ihr mich jetzt daran erinnern müssen, dass das so nicht das High-Performer-Mindset ist und ich mich nicht so anstellen soll.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber so wird das nix. Ich sehe es. Ihr habt auch nicht das High-Performer-Grindset-Mindset.
Da programmieren wir uns nicht auf den Mount Everest drauf.
Äußerst selten.
Ich glaube, das letzte ist zwei Jahre her oder so.
Aber das liegt an mir. Der hat mich vor, ich glaube, einem Jahr oder so, hat er mich mal angerufen, habe ich den SMS zurückgeschickt dann, als ich es gesehen habe, aber dann habe ich auch nicht mehr reagiert.
Eigentlich richtig assi. Weiß auch nicht.
Einer der wenigen, mit dem ich mich gut verstanden habe von YouTube.
Aber ihr wisst, wie das bei mir ist, so mit zwischenmenschlichen Sachen, womit YouTube aufgehört hat.
Das war, glaube ich, eher so ein schleichender Prozess.
Was? Shenzhen? Moment, was ist das für ein Game, bitte schön?
Shenzhen ist die China-Chinesen-Technik.
Okay, das ist ein guter Titel für ein Game.
Das ist ein guter Titel für ein Game.
Shenzhen.
Warum kann man da solitär spielen?
Das kenne ich, das habe ich schon mal gehört irgendwo.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was da geht.
Okay, Leute.
High-Performer-Frontend-Developer-Mindset.
Jetzt aber. Jetzt muss ich doch mal was tun hier jetzt.
Das kann es doch jetzt nicht sein.
Was ist hier los?
Okay, let's go.
Auf geht's. Massive Frontend stellt es jetzt.
Okay, auf geht's. Also wir brauchen...
Jetzt mal langsam anfangen.
So, wir brauchen eine Form.
Auf geht's. Forms.
Zack. Input.
Gebe mir hier Beispiele.
Auf geht's. Input.
Text-Area. Select.
Okay. Also.
Ich brauche Username und ich brauche Passwort.
So. Zack, zack.
Da haben wir es schon.
Input.
Titel. User.
Warum eigentlich ein Titel?
Wofür ist der Titel bei einem Input gut?
Das ist doch komplett umsonst, oder?
Placeholder. User.
So.
Weg damit.
Typ. Passwort. Richtig.
Typ. Passwort.
So.
Placeholder. Passwort.
So. Gut.
Dann kriegt das Ding vielleicht noch ein Label oben drüber.
Wobei, wer braucht ein Label, oder?
Label ist komplett overrated.
Chat, wie macht man ein hübsches...
Wie macht man ein hübsches Formular?
Schreibt man noch Labels oben drüber?
Oder reicht der Placeholder-Text?
Oder schreibt man Labels links daneben?
Wie macht das zum Beispiel...
Wie macht das zum Beispiel Google?
Oder so.
Login-Form-Example.
How to create a Login-Form.
W3schools.
Das ist die Seite.
Hier.
User. Okay. Label.
Die schreiben Labels oben drüber.
Ich glaube, es ist auch einfacher anzuklicken.
Erst Placeholder, dann den kleinen oben drüber.
Okay.
Label.
User.
Das ist gut so. Das gefällt mir.
Dann haben wir als nächstes das da.
Und noch ein Label oben drüber.
Ne, nicht User.
Passwort.
Oh, Leute. Feinfeld-Idee. Massive-Idee.
Passt mal auf. Jetzt.
Ich habe euch versprochen, Leute.
Only high-IQ-Javascript heute.
Aber bei Label das Vor-Attribut setzen. Warum?
Wenn ich das hier anklicke, geht es auch so.
So. Passt mal auf.
Achtung. Achtung.
Massive-File-Fat kommt jetzt.
Obacht. Obacht.
Ähm. Hier.
Icon.
Auge.
Ich hoffe, das heißt so. Auge.
Machst du Auge?
So. So. Und jetzt?
Und jetzt? Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf. Massive.
Wir machen das jetzt so, dass wenn man das Auge anklickt,
dass dann das Passwort sicher wird und
sichtbar wird und umgedreht.
So.
Type.
Wir brauchen mal eine Variable.
Let showPassword
gleich false.
Titel-Attribut ist für Screen-Reader.
Ach, wer braucht schon Screen-Reader?
Overrated.
Debated.
So. ShowPassword.
Wenn wir jetzt auf das Icon klicken.
Auf das Icon machen wir einen Button.
So. Button.
OnClick
showPassword gleich
not showPassword.
Oh. Okay.
Und der Type.
Der Type ist,
wenn es showPassword,
wenn showPassword,
dann ist der Type
Texts
und ansonsten ist der Type
Passwort.
Was ist jetzt das Problem?
Fail to execute on event target.
Javascript-Fehlermeldung.
Was willst du mir sagen?
Ach so.
Ah. Chat.
Ihr seid schlau.
Boah. Guckt mal hier.
Huge Feature.
So. Jetzt müssen wir das bloß noch ordentlich
platzieren.
Wo machen das die Leute meistens hin?
Hier so, gell?
Mach noch ein Autofocus
mal rein. Du meinst, wenn man hier
die Seite lädt, dass das automatisch
Gute Idee.
Wie macht man einen Autofocus
so?
Autofocus. Tatsächlich. Sehr gute Idee.
Chainlore.
Dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Leute. Premiere.
Chainlore postet sinnvolle Comments.
Anzeige direkte.
Abmahnung.
So. Das sieht jetzt allerdings ziemlich
kacke aus, so muss man ja mal sagen.
Das heißt,
die
Diese Buttons
machen die immer hier so rein, ne?
Ja, ja. Ich weiß. Ich weiß bloß nicht,
wo ich das hinmache. Am besten hier so
rein. Also.
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir mal
was ekliges.
Mir fällt nämlich nichts besseres ein.
Class.
Absolut.
Pop. Null.
Äh.
Ne. Ich muss das hier
auf relative
setzen. Skeleton hat
ein Focustab.
Ah.
Was hab ich hier? Ah.
Okay. Das ist cool.
Nein. Das wollte ich nicht.
Wie fehlt
das hier? Use
Focustrap.
Is focused.
Ne. Das mache ich einfach true und gut ist.
True Lulweh.
Avoid using autofocus.
Geh mal nicht auf den Keks, Alter.
Use autofocus.
Und das für?
Moment. Für was
mit dem autofocus?
Ach. Für ne Form. Da braucht man ein richtiges
echtes Form-Element drumherum.
Oder wie?
Okay.
Form.
Äh. Jetzt sieht es
anders aus.
Machen wir hier true.
Tap focus not defined.
Warum?
Muss man das
importieren?
Focustrap.
Jetzt ist es importiert.
Ne. Also wirklich gut
funktioniert das nicht.
Der selektet den Shit hiermit.
Kann man das ausschalten?
Es gibt doch
Es gibt doch hier
user select oder select.
Ach shit.
Okay. Das sackt. Das ist ja richtig dumm.
Was? Tap index
minus 1?
Das ist aber keine class, oder? Das ist
hier. Tap index
minus 1.
Also so wirklich gut funktioniert das nicht
Chat. Was die da gebaut haben.
Das springt dann raus.
Tja.
Dann würde ich sagen
Scheiße auf tap focus. Das kommt einfach wieder weg.
Wobei in der Form können wir es
trotzdem packen.
Vielleicht machen wir das nachher.
Was jetzt?
Och man. Javascript.
Wo ist das Problem? Alter.
Okay. Wunderbar.
So. Also.
Ich war doch grad bei meiner
High IQ Passwort
Anzeige
Icon. Klick. Ding.
So. Also. Guck dir mal. Wir müssen das jetzt ordentlich
platzieren. Top. Right.
0.
So. Right.
4 ist okay.
Und Top dann so 12 oder sowas.
8. Ja. Guck mal.
Genau in der Mitte. So muss das sein.
Und jetzt. High IQ move
Opacity 50%.
Ah. 60%.
Sieht doch richtig gut aus.
Jetzt kann man hier drauf klicken.
Und jetzt.
Es wird noch viel advance.
Wir brauchen noch
Icon. I
Cancel.
Tabler. Icons.
Ja genau. Sowas
will ich grad machen hier.
I.
I Pause. I off.
I off wollen wir haben.
I off.
Beste. I
off. Okay.
Wunderbar. So.
If.
Schau.
Passwort.
Dann. Und dann brauchen wir noch ein Else.
Langsam kann ich die hässliche
Svelte Syntax für If Else.
Ruhig sagen.
Das hat mir bei Vue doch besser gefallen.
So.
Bam.
Ne. Umgedreht oder?
Chat ist es so rum?
Doch so rum. Ne. Warte mal.
Zeigen wir an was das
Icon macht oder den aktuellen Stand.
So. Ne.
So ist schon okay oder?
Oder andersrum.
So. Also sprich.
Das mit dem Autofokus
nervt mich. Das will ich nicht.
Das ist gut. Das gefällt mir.
Nice.
So. Immerhin.
Heute.
High Performer Programmer Mindset.
Kannst class
Error auf das Passwort machen wenn es zu kurz ist.
Ja.
Validation und so. Da kommen wir jetzt erst noch hin.
So. Username Passwort.
Okay. Weiter gehts. Weiter gehts.
Ähm. Dann.
Können wir auf
Weiter klicken. Und wenn wir weiter klicken
können wir dann sowas wie Intervall oder so einstellen.
Also es müssen ja mehrere
Sachen erfüllt sein.
Der Account. Ich muss jetzt testen
ob der Account überhaupt
gültig ist.
Und bis das nicht funktioniert hat
kann man nicht auf
Weiter klicken.
Okay. Chat.
Jetzt ist die Frage.
Also. Entweder
machen wir das jetzt so
dass wir sagen es gab doch
irgendwie sowas wie Dis... Ne nicht Disabled.
Locked. Genau.
Man konnte doch sagen
Locked True.
So. Dass es nicht weiter geht. Also sprich.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Varianten.
So. Mal ne Frage an
die Fiveheaders unter euch.
Was ihr für
was ihr für besser
haltet.
Und zwar
einen Button
Ich mach das jetzt mal
exemplarisch.
Einen Button. Keine Ahnung.
Login.
Last gleich Button
Button
Variant
Fill
Fill Outline Primary. Irgendwie sowas.
Und da brauchen wir
noch Margin Top 2.
Also sagen wir irgendwie sowas hier.
Nur mal so exemplarisch.
Wir können das jetzt so machen.
Wir machen hier einen Login Button.
Und wenn ich hier auf Login klicke und das Login ist erfolgreich
dann wird der nächste Step
freigegeben. Oder
wir schauen mal ob man
den Next Button selber
nicht zum Login Button
umbauen kann.
Also.
Nur so. Machen wir mal so.
Keine Ahnung. Aber hier.
Let's. Keine Ahnung.
Login. Gleich
False.
Next gleich Login. Das andere ist verwirrend.
Okay.
Geht es jetzt um Einloggen oder
Account Adden? Naja. Es geht
eigentlich um beides.
Wenn du den Account addest, muss
bevor der Account geadded wird,
überprüft werden ob der Account
gültig ist. Weil es macht ja keinen Sinn
einen Account zu adden wo das Passwort nicht gültig ist.
Also da kann man ja schon gleich mal
beim hinzufügen mal einen Check machen.
Also so ist das
verwirrend meint ihr. Okay.
Dann
machen wir das weg.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal bei dem
Stepper gucken.
Stepper.
Wie man das einstellt ordentlich.
Hier. Next. Next. Next. Okay.
Wie designt
man die Buttons?
Button. Navigation
slot. You may overwrite
the content of the disabled.
Moment. Was?
Only first step?
Nee. Ich will die Buttons überhaupt
generell selbst machen.
Ich will keine Buttons von euch benutzen.
Du hast das vor wenigen Tagen auch gemacht.
Poggers. Da weißt du sicherlich noch wie das
funktioniert.
Event Handlers. Was haben wir denn
hier?
On next.
Nee. File Buttons ist Datei öffnen.
Also was haben wir denn? Properties.
Stamp badge.
Border start.
Button back. Hier.
Provide arbitrary
classes to style
the back button. Okay.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Das Problem ist
Next Label. Das ist gut.
Sehr schön.
Das brauche ich.
Und worauf setzt man das?
Next Label.
Hier im Step.
Next.
Next Label.
Keckel. Ja.
Aber Moment. Das hat ja immer
noch dieses blöde Locked Icon.
Das will ich doch gar nicht.
Ja doch. Es ist ja auch Locked.
Okay.
Aber es soll nicht Locked.
Nee. Das ist...
Moment. Moment.
Das Locked kann man eigentlich weg machen.
Okay.
Dann nennen wir das jetzt Login.
Ja. Das ist gar nicht so
übel. Login.
Ja. Aber es ist doof. Ich kann
beispielsweise set a type
of the next button.
String Button.
Ich würde gerne einfach ein eigenes
ein komplett
eigenen Button da übergeben können.
Dann nutze nicht den Stepper.
Ja. Aber dann muss ich so viel selbst
machen.
Das funktioniert ja prinzipiell.
Jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich noch
subscriben zum On Next
Event.
Machen wir mal hier Function.
Function. Ja genau.
Next.
Gibt es da irgendein Event?
Custom Event.
Next. Kann ich das irgendwie
auch abbrechen?
Das Event
irgendwie cancel?
Prevent
default heißt es doch, oder?
Bei Events. Also sprich
zack zack zack. Nee. Das funktioniert
nicht. Kann man vielleicht
return false oder so machen?
Ich will ja
nicht, dass es navigated.
Es navigated.
Trotzdem.
E. Stepper. Gab es das hier?
Ach hier. Detail.
State Current.
Default Prevented.
Muss man das so
machen?
Ich will das
navigieren abbrechen.
Okay. Events. On Next.
Hires when the next button is pressed
per step. Ja okay. Aber ich muss es ja auch
irgendwie abbrechen können. Den Next
Button. Ich hab
eine Idee. Vielleicht
muss man das in Kombination machen.
Okay. Moment.
Let locked gleich false.
Vielleicht muss man das irgendwie in Kombination
machen, um das abzubrechen.
Da sind die
Docs jetzt ziemlich kacke.
Locked
gleich. Nee. Was muss ich machen?
Nee. Doch so.
Locked.
Und jetzt sage ich
einfach locked gleich
true.
Nee.
Es hat schon navigated.
Okay. Event.
JavaScript.
Prevent.
Default.
Was haben wir?
Propagation.
Stop Propagation. Okay. Haben wir auch noch.
Vielleicht so.
Fuck. Wie geht denn das?
Okay.
Kann das sein, dass das die
Skeleton UI Dudes gar nicht vorgesehen haben?
Also
wirklich prevent default. Will ich ja auch
nicht. Ich will.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Das muss man
irgendwie abbrechen können.
Ja aber das wird es wahrscheinlich auch
nicht bringen.
Ich will ja
Das Problem
ist, dass ich hier,
wenn ich auf next klicke,
erst einen Check machen will, ob das Login
funktioniert hat.
Stop immediate propagation.
Was gibt es denn da noch alles?
JavaScript
hat so viel Zeug.
Ne.
Was kann man da noch machen?
Details.
Current. Total.
Step 0.
Return value true.
Moment. Muss ich den
return value irgendwie
ändern?
On Step Händler.
Zeig mal her.
On Step gibt es nicht. Ne.
Oder gibt es hier sowas wie On?
Ach On Step.
Moment. Das steht in den Docs nicht drin.
Was ist das?
Keine Docs dafür.
Ja.
Low IQ Docs
würde ich sagen.
Ich mach das auch mal on next. Mal gucken, was das für unterschiedliche Events sind.
Ah. Es ist Feuer bei.
Es gibt einmal Step und Next.
State Current 1.
Total 2.
Und das
Next Event sagt
Step 0.
State Current 1.
Total.
Aber wie halte ich
das denn jetzt davon ab?
Du bist nicht mehr im Usage Tab. Das stimmt.
On
Step. Tatsächlich.
Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein,
dass man das stoppt.
Vielleicht. Okay.
Hier gibt es Return Value drin.
Kann man da sowas sagen wie
E Return Value gleich
False.
Warum?
Okay. Ich hab eine Idee.
Throw
Exception.
Wie wirft man
Exception in JavaScript?
Wie geht denn das überhaupt?
Hier. Throw. Okay.
Throw. Keckel.
Pass mal auf. Jetzt war was kaputt.
Kannst du nicht einfach Step
gleich noch? Ah. Sogar.
Alter.
Sogar eine Exception da drinnen.
Hä?
Geil.
Sogar eine Exception da drin ist ihm egal.
Und er navigiert einfach weiter. Okay.
Ja. Dann weiß ich
auch nicht, wie man das Ganze stoppt.
Okay. Was wir machen können
ist vielleicht noch
Details. Ne.
Was ein Kack. Warum ist das schon wieder so
kompliziert gemacht?
Ich glaube.
Was du meinst? Ich soll es so machen? Das ist doch eigentlich kein
Unterschied, oder? In dem Fall.
Jetzt kriege ich natürlich auch die Sachen
nicht übergeben.
Ne. Das ist schon gut so. Das ist schon richtig so.
Den On Step Händler
aus Usage.
Gibt es nicht.
Die haben kein Beispiel.
Die haben kein Beispiel dafür.
Die haben nur das.
Ach doch. Da oben.
Event Step.
What the fuck? Das ist ja
High IQ
Function Händler.
Hast du öfters Programmierstreams? Ja.
Ach. Da ist Typescript
gedönst mit drin.
Alter.
Kriegt man das vielleicht doch irgendwie ordentlich?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das
anpassen muss. Dass das ent-
Typescriptet wird.
Was machen die da überhaupt?
Was ist das? Was bin ich hier sehend?
Das ist nur relevant für Typescript,
oder?
Was ist das hier überhaupt?
Das hier ist eine Typescript Type Annotation.
Das hat
nichts mit dem zu tun, was
es eigentlich macht. Also im Prinzip ist mein
Next Händler und das hier schon
genau das gleiche.
Die greifen nämlich dann zu auf
Detail.
Und dann auf Step.
So.
Und da ist es 0.
Okay.
Jetzt ist beides 0.
Das ist ja hängen geblieben, Alter.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Ich glaube,
ehrlich, man kann das nicht.
Aufhalten zu navigieren.
Nö.
Ja, das ist ja
richtig dumm.
Vielleicht prevent default
auf dem Login Button.
Oh, das ist ja dumm.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nicht gedacht.
Skeleton UI.
Stepper.
Wir gehen jetzt mal auf GitHub und gucken, was es da
wenn ich mal nach Stepper suche,
ob es da
okay, neue Stepper Component.
Changeable Next Button in
Stepper. Stepper on Next
prevents Step. Ja.
Okay, die locken das.
Ja, das ist ja
richtig dumm.
Offtopic Max nutzt
Manjaro. Nein, ich bin kein
Manjaro Peasant mehr. Ich bin ein
offizieller Archlinux
User.
By the way.
Manjaro, Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Dazu kann ich nur
sagen.
Was ist jetzt los, Alter?
Okay, Leute, das funktioniert nicht,
was ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Ich baue jetzt seit einer halben Stunde
an dieser kacke Login-Form rum.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Man kann den Stepper nicht preventen.
Das ist extrem dumm,
dass das nicht funktioniert.
Das geht nicht.
Man kann das nicht preventen.
Ich glaube,
wir können das nicht benutzen.
Was gibt es denn auf dem Stepper noch für Dinge?
On Back
Complete Next Step
Button Back, Button Label
Start
Was ist Start?
Ach so, Initial.
Wenn es auch schon auf GitHub
sogar ein Feature Request zu gibt,
dann wird das einfach nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ja mega dumm.
Da muss ich das selbst machen, oder wie?
Dass ich das ordentlich designe.
Das ist doch nix.
Das ist aber auch blöd.
Das ist alles nur dran rum gedoktert.
Ich habe noch nicht mal einen Login-Promise.
Ich habe einfach nur einen Button.
Kannst du in Step 2 wieder auf Step 1 umleiten?
Nein, ich kann überhaupt nicht umleiten.
Man kann mit diesen Events
nichts beeinflussen.
Das ist dumm.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Okay, Leute.
Wir bauen das jetzt einfach selbst.
Was habt ihr vorgeschlagen?
Nee, wie willst du das steuern?
Du kannst den Login-Button ausschalten.
Okay, das kannst du machen.
Das bringt dir aber nichts.
Du kannst nichts steuern.
Das Einzige, was du machen kannst,
ist, du kannst darauf reagieren,
wenn Next gepresst wird,
aber das nicht unterbinden.
Ich will den Login aber hier.
Bevor ich weitermache,
will ich, dass das Login
überprüft wird, weil ansonsten
ist das ziemlich dumm.
Dann könnte ich jetzt hier Zeug einstellen
und dann wird es überprüft
und dann muss ich wieder auf Step 1 zurück.
Das ist doch dumm.
Bau doch einen Login-Button.
Das habe ich ja am Anfang gesagt.
Das könnte man machen.
Guck, habe ich sogar noch hier unten drin.
Man könnte einen Login-Button machen
und wenn man da draufklickt,
dann wird das ver-
Aber das ist doch auch doof.
Der Chat hat recht gehabt,
das ist mega confusing.
Leg einen Hide-Button über den Next-Button.
Ja, genau.
Ich mache einen Fake-Login-Button
und wenn der okay ist,
dann st-
Nee, nee, nee. Das wollen wir nicht.
Komm, wir machen das einfach selbst.
So schwer wird doch so ein Stepper nicht sein, oder?
Mit
E Detail State Current
Okay, probieren wir das mal.
Log
E Detail
State
Current
Ich glaube nicht, dass man es beeinflussen kann.
Vor allem wie Current schon auf 1 steht,
eigentlich
Wait a minute.
Current 1
Total 2
Das steht auf dem letzten Step schon.
Damit kann man gar nichts-
Das steht schon auf dem ersten.
Damit kann man gar nichts beeinflussen.
Nee, das kann man nicht beeinflussen.
Ich meine, ich kann sagen State
Current gleich 0 oder so.
State
Current
Aber 0 gibt es ja nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist, weil 0
nicht gültig ist, oder?
Minus 1
Cac Java
Script. Okay, Current 0.
Alles klar. Ich weiß nicht,
warum- Leute, das Problem ist
jetzt, dass es halt einfach nur
Undefined Behavior. Das kann sein,
dass es- dass es kaputt
geht beim nächsten
Update. Kann einfach sein,
dass es breakt und fixiert.
Okay.
Das ist so die Frage. Können wir das irgendwie sinnvoll
überschreiben? Okay. Machen wir
mal einen Test. Machen wir mal einen Test.
Also, hier.
Keine Ahnung. Let Login
gleich- Was weiß ich?
Okay.
Okay. Nee, das ist-
Login
Okay. Gleich. False.
Wobei, muss ich gar nicht machen. Wenn ich hier
1 reinschreiben, wird es einfach funktionieren. Okay.
Aber dann funktioniert das Back
nicht mehr. What the fuck?
Okay. Und Step
brauche ich aber wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja gut. Jetzt.
Jetzt funktioniert's. Okay.
Funktioniert. Alles gut. Nice.
Sehr schön. GG Eats.
Also, man muss iDetailStateCurrent
stellen. Den anderen Krempel kann ich doch
eigentlich sein lassen, oder? Den brauchen wir doch gar nicht.
Es muss einfach 0 reingeschrieben werden. Okay.
Nice. Sehr agiler Stream.
Ja. Nice. Sehr schön. Gut.
Dann müssen wir jetzt mal
ein Login faken,
würde ich sagen.
Wie faken wir dann am besten? Wir machen das
einfach nur kleinstseitig. Okay.
Wir brauchen hier Login
States. Login States brauchen wir sowas
wie None. Also, wir haben
noch gar nicht versucht, uns einzuloggen.
Sowas wie Okay. Gibt es
eigentlich mittlerweile Enums in Javascript?
Ich glaube nicht, gell?
TypeScript hat Enums. Javascript selbst noch nicht.
Oder? Javascript
Enum. Was war denn das?
Da gibt es was, was
Code heißt.
Moment, es gibt doch Enums in Javascript.
Was ist das?
Seit wann denn das?
Nee, das ist doch
gar kein Enum. Das ist ganz normal einfach
eine
Dictionary.
Wobei?
Aber dafür kann man das benutzen.
Kann man das hier auch
einfach weglassen?
Eigentlich gar nicht dumm.
Wollen wir sowas machen?
Was brauchen wir denn? Wir brauchen sowas wie None.
Alter, das ist ja mega.
Wir machen String Vergleich.
Also,
das fängt an mit None.
Wir brauchen dann
noch sowas wie None,
Okay, Error
und irgendwie sowas wie
Waiting oder sowas.
Weil None ist
der Startstand. Okay ist, wenn das Login
Error ist, wenn das Login
nicht funktioniert, dann müssen wir das einfärben.
Und Wait, dass ich irgendwas anzeigen kann,
während es am Laden ist.
So, das machen wir jetzt mal. Function
Nehmen wir mal
TryLogin
Das faken wir jetzt einfach mal.
Wir setzen
Login auf Wait.
Das kann man bestimmt schöner machen.
Und dann sagen wir sowas wie
SetTimeout
Set
Timeout
Nach einer Sekunde
setzen wir
Login dann auf
Okay
Das kann man noch
bestimmt schöner machen.
Also ich meine, das ist jetzt ja nur zum testen.
So, also
Das erste, was wir checken
müssen ist, lass mal überlegen.
Lass mal kurz
in mich gehen. Wir müssen jetzt
testen. Okay, TryLogin
Passiert, wenn man
OnNext passiert das ganze.
OnNext
TryLogin
Jetzt müssen wir nur mal den Status
anzeigen, um zu gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Login ist
None, Login ist Wait.
Okay, CheckWait. Und jetzt ist
Login okay.
Nach einer Sekunde. Okay, prinzipiell
funktioniert das. None
Wait und nach einer Sekunde geht es auf Okay.
So, jetzt müssen wir nur den passenden
State dafür anzeigen.
Oh, Leute!
Nächste Sixthead-Idee!
Wir machen einen Spinner
in den Login-Button rein.
Wobei, wie kriege ich einen Spinner in den
Login-Button? Ich kann den
Login-Button ja nicht customisen.
Oh, das ist dumm,
Alter!
Wie könnte ich den Login-Button?
Wie könnte ich den Login-Button
customisen?
Ähm...
OnNext? Hier gab es doch irgendwas.
Props. Set the type
of the complete button.
Kann ich da auch eine Svelte-Component
nehmen, einfach?
Eine Stunde Spinner, da müssen wir jetzt durch.
Kann ich hier einfach
Button-Complete-Type. Kann ich da nicht
einfach eine Svelte-Component
angeben?
Button-Complete-Type.
Keckel.
Oder muss ich da
Typ-Diff angeben?
Macht das überhaupt was? Ach nee.
Es ist Button-Next-Type.
Typ-Diff?
What?
Ach, das ist
für einen Form.
Das ist für den...
Okay, das ist doof. Das heißt, es bleibt immer ein Button.
Ich kann das nicht customisen.
Kann das nicht...
Das ist ja so blöde gemacht.
Ich wollte da jetzt nämlich
einen Spinner reinsetzen.
Aber doch.
Eine Sache können wir machen.
Wir können
ja CSS-Klassen angeben.
Ohne UI-Library
weniger Kopfschmerzen. Ohne Mist.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin fast dafür,
auch das selber zu machen.
Da lernt man auch mehr.
Was wir machen können ist, wir können
Label angeben und wir können angeben,
Button...
Button-Next...
Nee, was? Wie geht das? Button...
Man konnte doch hier Farbe
und Style und sowas angeben.
Kann man nicht?
Hier. Button-Next.
Da kann man doch Klassen angeben.
Da kann ich dann sowas sagen wie
BG Black oder so.
Ja. Genau. Und...
Na gut.
Du kannst einen Spinner neben dem Button...
Das mach ich jetzt auch. Das machen wir jetzt.
Das ist richtig...
Richtig dumm, man. Ich wollte...
Ich will eigentlich
auf dem Button ein Icon haben
für Login
und einen Spinner, wenn man sich...
Ja, das ist doch mega dumm, Alter.
Warum ist das so unflexibel?
Warum gibt es nicht eine Komponente hier irgendwie
drin? Ähm... Button.
Mach es selber.
Würde mich sehr interessieren. Ja, mich auch.
Mich auch.
Aber ich glaub, so schwer ist das nicht.
Wie konnte man noch mal
an Buttons Icons anhängen?
Das ging doch irgendwie mit CSS.
Äh... Prepend
oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee. Before. Content.
Content.
Aber das geht mit Tailwind nicht.
Nee. Och. Das ist...
Das ist blöd.
Einfach innerhalb des Buttons ein I.
Es gibt kein innerhalb des Buttons.
Ich hab keinen Zugriff auf die
Button. Auf den Button.
Da drin.
Das wäre ja einfach. Ich mein, wir können mal was
ausprobieren hier.
Oh nee, es funktioniert nicht.
Hätte ja sein können.
Leute, ich fürchte,
wir müssen den Stepper selbst machen.
Okay. Passt auf.
Chatge ist FireFat.
Was?
Button eigen...
Und Label... Ja, aber...
Hä? Das hat doch da... Chat.
Das hat doch damit gar nichts zu tun.
Ich kann natürlich jetzt hier sowas sagen wie...
Bei dem Label?
Leute.
Ihr seid verwirrt.
Dieses Label dort
hat nichts mit dem Button zu tun.
Das ist das Label vom User.
Dieser Button da unten.
Den bringt diese Component mit.
Der ist nicht von mir.
Achso. Button next Label.
Das ist einfach nur der Text.
Aber vielleicht.
Mit rein basteln. Aber ich glaube...
Glaube nicht.
Das kann es doch jetzt echt
nicht sein.
Das kann es doch jetzt wirklich nicht sein.
Oder?
Okay.
Okay. Probieren wir mal was aus.
Icon?
Welches... Moment.
Mein Spinner. Wo ist denn mein Spinner?
Das ist doch echt
nicht Sinn und Zweck.
Okay. Lass mal kurz was gucken.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal
ein Icon. Wir machen jetzt testweise
ein Icon rein. Gucken ob das funktioniert.
Nein. Seht ihr Leute?
Das würde doch nicht mal funktionieren mit dem Icon.
Also.
Sind wir wieder
bei Step 1.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wisst ihr was ich blöd finde?
Normalerweise kannst du
mit Svelte sowas wunderbar machen.
Guckt euch das hier mal an.
Oder guckt euch hier die Account Card an.
Du kannst sagen, Section
oder äh ne.
Ich glaube hier ist gar kein Beispiel.
Du kannst dieses Svelte Fragment Syntax
Slot Syntax benutzen.
Und das könnten die genauso für Button machen.
Haben sie aber nicht.
Ne. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich glaube das kriegen wir mit dem
eingebauten Stepper nicht hin.
Das blöde ist nur, mal ernsthaft.
Ich will den Stepper auch nicht selbst machen.
Weil guckt mal. Dann müsste ich
dann müsste ich dieses ganze Ding hier
selbst bauen.
Auf der anderen Seite so kompliziert
kann es ja eigentlich auch nicht sein. Oder?
Okay. Scheiß drauf. Wir machen das jetzt.
Weg mit dem Stepper Leute.
Direkt
direkt selbst HTML
stellst. Also.
Ja. Zack.
Stepper weg.
Diff. Jetzt muss ich
Six Head Teil machen.
Ähm.
Diff.
Klass. Gleich. Text.
XL.
Add Account.
Äh. Strong.
Ne. Strong.
Okay. Das sieht doch jetzt ungefähr
so aus wie das was wir da
vorher hatten. Vielleicht machen wir
dazwischen noch ein bisschen
noch ein bisschen
Abstand so in der Richtung.
Oder so. Sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus
jetzt. So. Jetzt brauchen wir zwei Buttons
unten. Okay.
Der Sarix hat was gebaut.
Okay. Ja.
Eigentlich ganz hübsch.
Das hast du einfach nur irgendwo gesucht.
Bei Google.
Das bauen wir jetzt selbst.
Mal gucken ob mir da was einfällt.
So. Wir brauchen
jetzt erstmal Buttons da unten.
Wie haben wir das hier gemacht mit den Buttons?
Section hier. Futter.
Buttons.
Machen wir jetzt
hier auch. Und dann
machen wir da eine eigene Component raus.
Weil ansonsten blicke ich hier nimmer durch.
Ich blicke jetzt schon nimmer durch.
Hier. Icon. Ne.
Hackle.
Okay. Nice. Okay.
Ähm.
Ich blicke jetzt schon nimmer durch. Moment.
Hier ist die Card. Wartet mal.
Wir müssen noch ein paar Leerzeichen rein machen.
So. Das da.
Muss weg.
Das ist okay.
Und wie ging das jetzt hier? Account.
Musste.
Ach ne. Man konnte auch direkt
einen Header nehmen. Okay. Das heißt
also es gibt eine
Section.
Blablabla.
Und es gibt
ein Header. Ja das können wir doch
dafür benutzen.
Und das ist. Moment. Ach Moment.
Das ist in der Card drinne.
Jaja. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Add Account.
Warum sieht das jetzt so ultra hässlich aus?
Hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Ich kopier mir das jetzt einfach mal hier. Zack.
Ich hab doch bestimmt
irgendwo wieder irgendwas hier falsch copy-pasted
oder so.
Hier.
Next.
Dieses ganze Krempel kommt weg.
Das kommt weg. Das kommt weg.
Hier.
Diff. Lul.
Und hier
kommt Add Account rein.
Okay. Das sieht doch schon
besser aus.
Moment. Jetzt fehlt das Card Diff.
Ach man. CSS
und HTML.
Also hier kommt noch ein Diff drum herum.
Ne.
An welcher Stelle?
Hier?
Okay. Das sieht doch
tatsächlich schon ganz brauchbar aus.
Und jetzt brauchen wir den
anderen Krempel wieder. Hier meine Form.
Die Form kommt da rein.
Ja. Okay.
Leute. Es sieht langsam aber sicher schon immer
besser aus.
Oh. Okay. Strong.
Nicht String.
Strong.
Ja. Nice. Nice. Okay. Das sieht doch jetzt schon
ein bisschen so aus wie es am Ende aussehen muss.
Nur dass da nicht Next stehen soll.
Sondern. Okay. Das kommt
weg.
Kleiner Button muss es auch nicht sein.
Filt Error. Boah.
Muss es.
Filt mit Error muss es auch nicht sein.
Es muss einfach nur ein Button.
Es muss ein Filt.
Variant.
Filt.
So?
Was ist denn schön für ein Next?
Filt.
Die Primary
sieht dumm aus.
Secondary sieht auch dumm aus.
Surface.
Naja.
Ganz ehrlich.
So war eigentlich schon fast am besten.
Ist Svelte sowas wie Bootstrap?
Nein. Svelte ist ein
Javascript Framework, was eigentlich
kein Javascript Framework ist.
Sondern wo möglichst viel Framework, wenn es
dann im Browser ausgeführt wird, verschwindet.
Das hier ist Skeleton UI.
Weil mein CSS geschisst drum herum.
So.
Ist nicht Next, sondern Login heißt
der Button.
Und der kommt auf die
rechte Seite. Was war das?
MS Auto? Ja.
Ok. Das sieht doch jetzt schonmal
gar nicht so kacke aus.
Oder?
Es sieht jetzt schonmal recht ähnlich zu dem
aus, was ursprünglich da war.
Vielleicht sollten wir
auch ein bisschen Abstand dazwischen machen.
Ne. Es ist ein
Login und dann ein Add.
Wir brauchen jetzt ein Icon für Login.
Login.
Gucken ob es ein bescheides Icon dafür gibt.
Icon.
Login.
Ups. Wenn man die Hälfte vergisst.
Gar nicht schlecht.
Gar nicht schlecht. Finde ich sogar ganz passend.
Margin left
2. Und jetzt machen wir es
noch ein bisschen
kleiner. Ich glaube 6 ist...
Ja.
Das sieht ganz brauchbar aus.
Finde ich jetzt.
Oder?
Das sieht doch schonmal
gar nicht so verkehrt aus.
Gebt mir
eure nice CSS Design
Tipps.
Ich glaube es ist nicht ganz...
Ich glaube es ist nicht
ganz richtig ausgerichtet.
Doch ist es
anscheinend. Zwischen User
und Passwort fehlt ein bisschen Wild Space.
Da hast du recht. Das sieht
richtig hässlich aus.
Können wir sowas machen wie...
Form
class
flex
Column
Gap 2? Hey!
Ach nee. Das ist
zwischen den Dingern.
Aber das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Da ein bisschen Gap dazwischen zu haben.
Wir sollten
vielleicht zwischen dem Label
hier
zwischen dem Passwort und dem Label
sollte man vielleicht ein bisschen was haben.
Class
Nee.
Oder ist es Padding?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken Leute.
Aber auf dem Span geht das wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Top 2?
Nee. Das funktioniert nicht
weil das alles in diesem Label drin ist.
Ehrlich gesagt
sollte einfach die Schrift
hier auch ein bisschen kleiner sein.
Und
Nee. Also das hier
ist Text
LG? Nee. Das ist Text
Base.
Ja. Wir wollen eigentlich nicht Text Base.
Wir wollen eigentlich Text SM vielleicht haben.
Ja oder?
Ich glaub das ist auch nicht schlecht. Oder was haben wir
sonst? SM. Bisschen kleiner
als dort. Schmoll.
Nee. Lassen wir das erstmal weg.
Also ich bin gerade nicht in der Lage
einen Abstand hier dazwischen hin zu
bekommen.
Weil Margin Top funktioniert
nicht.
Und Margin Bottom funktioniert auch nicht.
Das liegt ziemlich sicher daran
weil das alles in diesem Label gerappt ist.
Label ist ein
Inline Element. Das ist zwar wie ich keinen Plan davon habe.
Macht Block drauf.
Wo? Hier?
Hier?
Oder wo?
Jetzt Margin Top
2? Nee. Funktioniert nicht.
Der Button innerhalb des
Labels. Warum? Das macht man doch so.
Dachte ich. Der Button ist nicht
innerhalb des Labels. Der Login Button ist das
hier unten.
EDV Forensik. Danke für den Sub.
Der Button hier
ist im Label
damit ich hier drauf klicken kann.
Nicht dass das jetzt Best Practice wäre.
Ich hab bloß keine Ahnung was ich mache.
Nein. Margin funktioniert nicht.
Weil ich gerade gelernt habe Label
ein Inline Element ist.
Chat ist richtig
auf Zack heute. Wir müssen
uns jetzt erstmal damit zufrieden geben.
Dass das noch so ein bisschen hässlich aussieht.
So. Wir haben ein Login Button. Das ist doch schon
mal was. Haben die Buttons
in diesem Stepper
eigentlich auch so eine komische Animation gehabt?
Ja. Next.
Jetzt können wir das Ding nämlich designen wie wir wollen.
Wir haben ein Login Button.
Wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen zu Protokoll kommen.
Wir können ja an der Schriftart
die ganze Zeit rumwursteln.
Wir brauchen ein Button
für
Login und wir brauchen ein Button
auf der ersten Seite.
Brauchen wir ein Button für
Chat.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Ich glaube man muss
jetzt sagen.
Ja. Perfekt.
Und wir brauchen ein Button für
Cancel.
Moment. Falscher Knopf.
Der Cancel Button
der kriegt auch
kein Icon und so ein Kack.
So. Cancel und der kriegt
auch nicht Fill sondern der kriegt
Outlined
irgendwie.
Irgendwie so. Der soll ein bisschen unauffällig
aussehen. Wenn ihr bessere Ideen
habt von der Farbe sagt Bescheid.
Login. Cancel. Wunderbar.
Ich würde es tauschen.
Nee. Das ist okay.
Das ist okay. Oder meint ihr
Login links?
Äh.
Ja. Wir kommen jetzt erst zum zweiten
Step gleich.
Die Sachen mit wo Buttons
passiert sind und so. Das kann man ja noch
alles ändern. So. Jetzt müssen wir gleich noch
wieder
OnlyHigherQ JavaScript machen.
Und zwar. Wenn Login
gedrückt wird. So. Achtung.
Wenn Login gedrückt wird
dann geht
Login auf
Wait. Das heißt
wenn Login
gedrückt wird. Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz
einbauen. Hier.
OnClick
Ich glaube Next hieß das Ding.
Next. Nee. Wie habe ich das da oben
genannt? Ach nee. TryLogin.
TryLogin.
So.
Wenn
TryLogin gemacht wird
dann soll
das Disabled werden. Der Button in der
Zwischenzeit. Oder? Ich glaube das
ist nicht verkehrt.
If Login gleich
gleich Wait.
Okay. Das funktioniert schon mal.
Guck mal. Nach einer Sekunde
enabelt er sich wieder. Okay. Nice.
Und jetzt zeigen wir
einen Spinner an.
Wenn der Login-Button
gerade Login macht.
Im Background. Das klingt doch
eigentlich ganz sinnig. Wo haben wir hier
meinen Spinner? Dort.
Okay. Icon.
Äh. Ganz
Shit hier weg.
Progress.
Das sieht gar nicht so übel aus. Also ich meine das Icon
ist noch weg.
Was ist Svelte? Svelte ist
ein Frontend-Framework.
Was möglichst wenig Framework ist.
Also sprich.
Es gibt keinen E-Namen.
Javascript kann
keine E-Namens.
Das ist ein Javascript-Framework
was das Ziel hat
wenn du es dann im Browser laufen lässt
möglichst wenig vom Framework noch übrig
zu haben.
Das ist kein Timescript. Nee.
Plain.
Nee. Vanilla.
Vanille. Javascript.
Hier. If.
Also. If.
Login.
Aber das machen wir
das nochmal. Wait. Das kann man bestimmt
noch verschönern.
Was war? Oh nee.
Wie ging das jetzt? Ich hab's
vergessen. If.
Ah. Slash. If.
So. Wenn es
Equate ist. Okay. Das funktioniert
schon mal.
Else. Else.
Das Normale.
Ja.
Ja. Schon mal ganz gut.
B5.
2.
Ja. Leute.
Das find ich ganz hübsch. Das hat was.
Guck mal.
Das ist richtig gut. Da weißt du gleich.
Es ist disabled. Und er macht was
im Hintergrund. Das gefällt mir.
Das find ich optisch
sehr schick. Dazu kann ich
nur sagen.
Only HiIQ
Javascript heute.
Ich hab übrigens gehört, dass PrimeSubLang
besser ist als C++.
Das Repo
für PrimeSubLang hab ich auf GitHub
schon erstellt.
Login. Das ist schick.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
So. Ich mein.
Das hat null Funktionalität bisher.
Aber es sieht schon mal schick aus.
Kann man Cancel drücken?
Wie sieht es in LightTheme aus?
Eigentlich auch ganz brauchbar, oder?
Nur, dass ich das Grün
nicht mag, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaub, da muss ich
ein eigenes Theme bauen.
Bau ein Regex
fürs...
Nee. Das mach ich anders mit Validierung
für Form. Weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Übrigens. Jetzt hab ich den
SubSellout so verklausuliert,
dass es keiner gecheckt hat.
Aber unabhängig von PrimeSubSellout.
Ohne Sellout jetzt.
Wenn euch die Streams gefallen und ihr öfter
sowas sehen wollt, könnt ihr auch
PrimeSubben, aber darauf will ich gar nicht raus.
HiIQ-Leute. PrimeSubben.
Nee. Ihr könnt auch followen.
Das freut mich auch und das kostet euch auch nix.
Und ihr müsst auch nicht das Geld
von Besos verschwenden mit dem PrimeSub.
Wobei wir nicht nur Frontend-Stells
machen. Wir machen alles möglich. Wir haben
Microcontroller schon gemacht. Wir haben
gelötet im Stream. Wir haben Heimautomatisierung
gemacht. Wir haben Sachen schon gespielt.
Wir haben C++
fucking C++ gemacht
schon, ja. .NET
Backend-Zeug. Alle möglichen Sachen.
Funktioniert
jetzt der Tab-Index?
Nö. Da bin ich auch
viel zu blöd für.
Das macht doch eh keiner, oder?
Drückt doch eh keiner Tab bei sowas.
Kannst du noch sagen, warum du dich fürs Welt entschieden hast?
Ja, weil es mir gefällt.
Zott-Validator. Gibt es dort sowas wie Formic?
Keine Ahnung. Die coolen Leute
verwenden alle Zott.
Hab ich noch nie benutzt. Wie gesagt,
ich bin kein hauptberuflicher und auch kein
nebenberuflicher Frontend-Entwickler.
So. Also wir müssen jetzt mal
ein bisschen weiter bauen. Login.
Es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten, was passieren kann
bei dem Login.
Das erste ist, Login ist okay.
Dann geht er auf die zweite Seite.
Das andere, was passieren kann,
ist, Login ist Error
und Login ist Error.
Bedeutet,
ich muss hier was anzeigen
lassen,
dass es einen Fehler
gegeben hat.
Dann machen wir das doch jetzt mal.
Label
Input.
Da gab es sowas wie Error. Das habe ich gesehen.
WG Error.
Label Error.
Ne, wie heißt denn das?
Input Error?
Ja, genau.
So, Input Error gibt es,
wenn... Das ist nicht schön.
Das kann man bestimmt besser machen.
Das ist viel zu viel Inline-Java-Skript
Zeug, was dann später kein Mensch mehr lesen kann.
Login gleich...
Wir können da eine eigene Komponente draus
machen, auf jeden Fall.
Aus den Inputs hier. Dann wird es ein bisschen übersichtlicher.
Okay, checken wir das mal. Login schlägt
fehl und es geht nicht.
Warum? Achso!
Weil ich nichts angegeben habe.
Wenn Login gleich
Error, dann Input
Error.
Okay,
zack zack. Login schlägt fehl.
Sehr schön. Schick.
Gefällt mir. Hat was.
Das gleiche
gibt es jetzt auch noch für
das Passwort-Feld.
Tvoris.
Danke für den Sub.
Cedox. Pog-Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Funktioniert das schon mal. Sehr nice.
Ich glaube, wir sollten noch was anderes
machen. Und zwar
das hier ist disabled.
Alter, jetzt geht es aber richtig zur Sache
hier. PTM.
Dankeschön. Oder nee. PTIM.
Nicht PTM. PTIM.
Ich habe gehört...
Der Scam-Train ist am Start, Leute.
Du hast nur wenige Zeit.
Oh mein Gott, Leute.
Besos muss ins Weltall fliegen.
Glücklicherweise.
Ab und zu muss Sellout ein bisschen...
Aber ich bin echt überrascht.
Feeld-Stream lohnt sich. Wer hätte das nur denken können?
Ich habe so viele Subs gerade wie
noch nie vorher.
Begeistert. Und Feeld-Stream
heißt bei mir 2-3 Stunden
alle
1-2 Tage mal. Ich muss gar kein
Full-Time-Streamer
8 Stunden am Tag machen.
Ja, SargeSilver,
du hast 20 Subs gegiftet.
Das hat auf jeden Fall mitgeholfen.
25.
Okay. So. Jetzt.
Wo wollte ich stehen? Genau. Also.
Guck mal. Wir setzen das hier auf
Disabled, wenn es auf Wait ist.
Wir müssen aber auch
es auf Disabled setzen,
wenn
User
nicht gesetzt ist.
Nee, nicht Login gleich.
User.
Binde ich das überhaupt schon irgendwo?
Nee, ich kacke nur.
Wait. Value.
User.
So.
Let User gleich.
Jetzt kann ich sagen
User, solange
User nicht gesetzt ist,
ist es auch Disabled. Guck.
Und erst wenn ich was eintippe in User,
dann wird der Login-Button
aktiv.
Und jetzt hat Login nicht geklappt, jetzt gibt es einen Fehler.
Nice. Das ist schick. Das gefällt mir
sehr gut. Exzellent.
Lupus Oculus.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sogar Hype Train Level 2.
So.
Dann gibt es jetzt noch.
Nee, das war es eigentlich.
Zack, zack. Login.
Fehler wird angezeigt.
Cancel. Ja doch. Cancel können wir noch gleich
implementieren. Cancel wird relativ
easy.
Wo ist der Cancel-Button?
Cancel.
Cancel ist ganz einfach.
On, klick.
Go to.
Nee, da müssen wir so machen.
Dahin.
Was jetzt?
Go to is not defined.
Äh.
Wie heißt das nicht so?
Import from Svelte.
Heißt das nicht Go to?
Nee.
Shit.
Ähm.
Ach hier. From App Navigator.
Meine Güte. Können die das Zeug auch irgendwie mal so nennen,
dass man es findet?
So und wenn ich jetzt Cancel drücke, dann kommt
man nämlich wieder eins zurück.
Okay.
Ich finde Svelte plus Tailwind
halt nice, weil man das ja auch für
Kleinkram. Das ist ein richtig Kleinkram,
was ich hier mache. Das hat am Ende zwei, drei Seiten.
Das war es. Und es gegenüber von
VHS einfacher ist und dann am Schluss mit einem gescheiten
Bildprozess die Seite nur zwei bis drei Kilobyte
overhead hat, dank Treeshaking und so weiter.
Ja, wie das funzt, habe ich auch
nicht so ganz durchgestiegen.
Seitengröße interessiert zwar heutzutage.
Naja, für die Loading Time schon irgendwo.
Nicht so wie Facebook, was
irgendwie erst mal 18 MB in JavaScript lädt.
Ja, was es ist, weiß ich,
aber wie das funzt, habe ich noch nicht
durchstiegen.
So.
Also jetzt können wir zumindest schon mal Abbrechen drücken.
Okay.
So, es gibt jetzt die Variante
hier. Das schlägt fehl und es gibt
also wenn es fehl schlägt, haben wir das ja eigentlich
schon mehr oder weniger alles gehandelt.
So.
Ja. Ich glaube,
mehr brauchen wir jetzt an der Stelle gar nicht,
oder? Ich meine, das ist doch schon
recht
selbsterklärend alles.
Gut.
Dann gehen
wir jetzt mal eins weiter.
So, und wenn das okay ist, was passiert
dann? Dann passiert noch nichts,
aber wenn das okay ist, dann soll er
eins weiter gehen.
Warum hast du ein Form,
dass es ordentlich formatiert wird? Wenn ich das Form
wegmache, sieht es glaube ich kacke aus.
Aber eigentlich bräuchten
wir das nicht, schon richtig.
Naja.
Im Großen, ja schon.
Das liegt aber jetzt eher an dem.
Wie machst du das
mit einer Registrierung?
Es geht darum, schon einen bestehenden
Account bei Fiat
sich einzuloggen. Da muss man nichts
registrieren.
Macaroni-Fahrrad. Sehr guter
Nickname.
Ich finde, zu viele Animationen taugen
nichts. Eigentlich ganz schick.
So, nächster Step.
Also, nächster Step.
Ja, ich kenne das da rechts, aber ich will
ja gar keine Form absenden aktuell.
So, nächster Step.
Wenn das okay ist, dann
gehe ich ein Step weiter.
Also, wir brauchen jetzt quasi sowas wie
Step
gleich 0.
Geht halt da los.
Und wenn das hier fertig
ist, dann...
Also, wenn Login okay ist, dann sagen wir Step gleich
1 oder sowas.
Und jetzt muss ich das
irgendwie umbauen. Das wird jetzt ein bisschen eklig,
weil ich keine einzelnen Komponenten
für die Sachen hier gemacht habe, sondern alles
auseinander geschrieben habe und man kann halt nichts
mehr erkennen. Ich finde das krass.
Wir haben nur 70 Zeilen.
Ja, was? Nur 70 Zeilen.
Oder nicht mal ganz. 50 Zeilen
HTML. Und du
siehst jetzt schon nichts mehr.
So, Step 1. Als
nächstes...
Also, die Buttons hier unten,
die bleiben ja gleich. Das
einzige, was sich ändert,
ist
die Section im Endeffekt.
Also,
if Step gleich 0.
Alles klar.
Das sollte jetzt einfach verschwinden gleich, wenn Login
durch ist. Jawohl, macht's auch.
Was zum Teufel ist jetzt los?
Ich versuche gerade zu erkennen, was das
überhaupt sein soll.
Was bin ich
da sehend gewesen?
Ich erkenne das nicht mal.
Ach, das ist ein... Okay, ja, jetzt...
Okay.
Ja, jetzt erkenne ich's.
Ja, hätte ich vielleicht besser nicht erkennen sollen.
So, jetzt sind wir bei Step
2.
Mehr Steps gibt's, glaube ich, auch nicht.
Step 2.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Login. Boom, zack, geht weiter. Step 2.
Gut, da gibt's jetzt wieder
eine Section.
Section.
Moment, ich hab nur die Form. Ach, ich hab nur die Form.
Okay, das war eigentlich ganz clever.
Das nur die Form ist.
Okay, jetzt brauchen wir...
So, im zweiten Step gibt's jetzt aber kein
Login-Button mehr.
Sondern
einen... Ach so, den Step...
Das ist... Okay, langsam wird's
eklig. Langsam wird's
eklig. So, Step 2
kriegt nämlich kein Login-Button mehr, sondern
ein, tja...
Completed- oder Add-Button
oder sowas.
Der Cancel-Button kann
da bleiben.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Nicht Login.
Step.
Else.
So, und im zweiten Step
hat dann das da unten halt... Ja, okay.
Passt. Ja, das muss man
tatsächlich ein bisschen
komponentisieren,
weil sonst kann das...
In spätestens zwei Tagen blick ich nicht mehr durch,
was ich hier gebaut hab.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
So, und da gibt's jetzt kein...
Das ist ja doof, jetzt muss ich... Guck mal, ich kann
jetzt standardmäßig aber einfach Step hier auf Ein
stellen, dann können wir uns das immer angucken. Zack.
So, Login.
Also wir wollen kein Login-Button
mehr haben. Das brauchen wir nicht. Disabled
wird der auch nicht. Try Login gibt's auch nicht
mehr.
Und ein Icon...
Weiß ich nicht, brauchen wir eigentlich auch nicht.
Sondern das heißt nicht Login, sondern
einfach nur Add oder sowas.
Oder
Save oder sowas.
Success.
So.
Und der Cancel-Button...
Ja, wobei, der
Cancel-Button kann eigentlich da bleiben. Zurück
zu Step 1 wollen wir ja nicht mehr.
Wenn alles eingeloggt, fertig, aus.
Zurück zu Step 1.
Wozu? Passwort war
gültig, weiter geht's.
Ansonsten Cancel und von vorne. Wir müssen ja nicht
übertreiben bei zwei Steps.
So, was da jetzt rein muss,
tatsächlich, da muss nochmal eine Form hin.
Wir werden die Form-Komponenten
in eine eigene Komponent machen.
Also die Form-Sachen.
So.
Und jetzt brauchen wir keinen User
und wir brauchen kein... Ja doch, doch,
doch, doch, brauchen wir.
Wir brauchen eine
PIN.
Jetzt brauchen wir nämlich kein Passwort, sondern eine PIN-Eingabe
brauchen wir noch. Die gibt's nämlich auch.
So. PIN.
Ja, das ist gut, das kann so
bleiben. Dann kann man PIN und so anzeigen.
Okay. PIN.
Ja, und hier gibt's keinen User. Eigentlich brauche
ich jetzt hier einen Slider.
Weil ich will, ich will das haben für
äh, so
Refresh quasi.
Refresh-Intervall.
Und da brauche ich einen
Slider.
Hat Skeleton gescheite,
gescheite Slider.
Slide. Slider.
Hier. Range Sliders.
Das klingt auch gut. So was hier.
Genau. Oh nee, oder?
Die verwenden die Native?
Verwenden die...
NOOO! Die Native Slider
funktionieren nicht richtig.
Das buggt immer rum
as fuck. Boah, ich zeige euch mal was.
Gucken, ob sie das mittlerweile gefixt haben.
Also, schaut mal her.
Firefox, total easy.
Funzt, ne? Auch wenn das Slider ein bisschen
hässlich aussieht, okay? Funzt.
So. Und jetzt passt mal,
passt mal auf Chrome.
Ihr seht, dass ich geklickt habe, ne?
Anhand der Farbe. Aber das Slider geht
einfach nicht. Jetzt, manchmal
geht's, manchmal geht's, jetzt geht's wieder nicht.
Jetzt geht's
wieder, jetzt geht's wieder nicht.
Es ist so fail, alter.
Jetzt geht's wieder, jetzt hängt's wieder.
Also, ohne Mist.
Der Native Slider
in... Guck mal, ist wieder kaputt.
Der Native Slider in Chrome ist einfach
so für'n... Alter, deswegen verwende ich das Ding nicht gerne.
Angeblich haben sie
null Support. Ha!
Leute, und wer hat wieder kein Support?
Wer hat wieder
kein Support dafür?
Wer ist es?
Es ist Safari! Wer hätte das gedacht?
Was sonst?
Safari nutzt eh
keiner. Ja, gut, plus alle
iOS-Benutzer und Mac-User.
Also, was ich gerne hätte, wäre
einen Slider. Ich mach das jetzt mal exemplarisch
hiermit, ja?
Ich hätte gerne einen Slider an der Stelle.
Refresh. Kein Input,
sondern einen Slider.
Range Slider.
Value 1.
Gibt's sowas?
Value 1. Gibt's sowas wie
Mindest, ja, Mindest
1?
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
A form label
must be associated with a control.
Nervt nicht.
So.
Was ich... Alter!
Oh Mann, ist das in Chrome kaputt,
dieses Ding. Alter, ist das...
Boah, ist das kaputt. Mal gucken, wie es in
Firefox funktioniert.
Ja, Firefox,
gar kein Problem. Funktioniert sofort.
Deswegen verwende ich diese Native Slider
nicht gerne. So.
Refresh.
Und, also, was ich gerne hätte, wie
das da Refresh steht, zum Beispiel
mal hier Refreshintervall
gleich eine Minute.
Hier. Bind.
Value. Find.
Find, Value, Refresh.
So, Maximum Minuten,
keine Ahnung, 30.
Step 1. Und jetzt
will ich sowas dahinter schreiben wie
Refresh
Minutes oder sowas.
Achso. Ja.
So.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz nice. Da kann man nämlich
einstellen, in welchem Intervall das Ganze
refreshen soll.
Und ehrlich, ich hätte es
lieber ohne diese komischen Tics.
Die nerven. So.
Bei mir funktioniert es in Chrome ja ohne
Probleme. Also hier gibt es
bei mir, bei mir buggt es rum.
Können wir es mal ausprobieren.
Wie es in Chrome funktioniert. Skeleton UI.
Vielleicht auch in den
Linux-Ding. Range
Slider. Warum machst
du nicht den Dropdown hin oder den Text
mit Max 30, yo?
Den Dropdown.
Man könnte einfach ein Number
Input Feld auch machen.
Essich Schurke, danke für den
Sub. Und sorry,
falls ich irgendwen übersehen habe. Ich guck grad nochmal.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Tatsächlich!
Leute, unter Windows
funzt es bei mir auch sofort.
Vielleicht, das scheint mir irgendein
Linux-Ding zu sein.
Dass der Chrome unter Linux rumbuggt.
Hier ist easy, gar kein
Problem. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Aber hier, und das hatte ich schon lange.
Und hier ist mega verbuggt.
Also auch hier auf der Seite im Chrome.
Auf der offiziellen.
Wie sieht denn
eigentlich ein Input Element aus
für ein Number?
Wie haben die das denn gestylt?
Zeigt mir hier.
Type Number.
Öh!
Was ist das? Ne, das will ich nicht.
Das sieht kacke aus.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Hype.
Oder es liegt an der VM?
Naja, aber im Chrome, äh sorry,
hier im Firefox, wenn ich das mal richtig treffen würde,
funktioniert das ja auch ohne Probleme.
Hier nicht,
hier nicht, aber hier.
Ja, und auch wenn man hier drauf klickt.
Wenn man trifft.
Ohne Probleme.
Weiß nicht, ob das wirklich...
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das an der VM liegt.
Aber mein möglich ist es.
Irgendwas muss ja der Unterschied sein, ne?
Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt noch
einen Abstand nach außen hin?
Kann ich hier sowas machen wie
Margin To?
Oder so?
Ne.
Ah ne, das ist die Karte, brauchen wir nicht hier.
Margin To?
Oh, okay.
Äh, Margin
X To.
Hier.
Okay.
Besser.
Ich kann mir übrigens immer noch nicht den Unterschied
merken zwischen Margin und Padding.
Margin ist außen,
Padding ist Teil vom Element.
Irgendwie so. Oder umgedreht?
Kann ich mir nie merken.
War richtig, okay.
Poggen.
Leute, wie findet ihr das besser?
Mit nem Slider?
Oder einfach ein Text Input,
wo man die Zeit eintragen kann in Minuten?
Oder,
haben die nen Dropdown?
Dropdown wär vielleicht auch nicht blöd.
Was haben die denn hier?
Forms?
Ja, dass du einstellen kannst.
Keine Ahnung, 1, 5, 15,
30 oder sowas.
Aber das sieht auch hässlich aus,
dieses Dropdown.
Ich hab's gerade gesehen.
Ich hab's schon vorhin gesehen.
Das ist ne lustige Idee hier mit dem Kippen.
Ach, das ist wieder was anderes,
was du gepostet hast.
Das mit dem Volume Slider
fand ich gut.
Okay, probieren wir das gerade nochmal aus.
Wie geht das hier?
Select Options.
Gucken wir mal,
ob das nicht zu hässlich aussieht.
Boah, Alter, das ist mega hässlich.
Boah, sieht das scheiße aus.
Mit dem Grün.
Ich find das Grün mega hässlich.
Einfach nur dafür.
Ne.
Weg.
Oh, Leute,
22 Uhr.
Was ist hier los?
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen gleich.
Kannst du doch das Theme ändern.
Ja, die sehen aber alle nicht gut aus.
Leute, ich glaube,
ich schmeiß Skeletten wieder raus
und mach das einfach alles vom Scratch.
Heute haben wir wieder
ein Teamwork gefightet,
anstatt dass wir irgendwelche Probleme
damit gelöst hätten.
Flowbite habe ich mir vor
eine ganze Weile, ich glaube schon vor
zwei Jahren oder so, mal angeguckt.
Das sah optisch sehr nice aus.
Es hat mich
aber irgendwas dran gestört.
An
Flowbite.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Vielleicht ist das auch weg, was mich gestört hat.
Wie das jetzt ausschaut.
Components.
Oh, Forms. Mal gucken.
Okay, mal gucken, wie bei denen
der Range Slider aussieht.
Die Frage ist, ist das ein Native
Range Slider oder ist das was
selbstgebautes?
Input Type Range, ja, dann sieht's wahrscheinlich
auf iOS auch kacke aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab meine VM schon ausgemacht.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob der funktioniert.
Guck mal, die haben sogar einen Spinner.
Der Spinner heißt, wo man sich merken kann,
was abgeht.
Aber sag mal so, oh, mein Auge.
Flowbite sieht standartmäßig schon
ein bisschen hübscher aus.
Toast. Aber Leute,
ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, ich lass das mit.
Das kenn ich, das kenn ich.
Das gibt es, aber
nicht die offizielle Variante für Svelte.
Es gibt so einen Nachbau oder so einen
inspiriert
von für Svelte.
Aber
mit bei weitem nicht allen Komponenten.
Ne. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich hab die Maus immer noch gedrückt.
Buckt immer noch.
Ja, Bootstrap. Mit Bootstrap fang ich
jetzt nicht an. Bootstrap.
Lul.
Lul, Bootstrap.
Svelte ist es egal, was ich nehme.
Naja, nicht unbedingt.
Wenn es React
Komponenten sind, kann ich die nicht
in Svelte benutzen und umgedreht.
Obviously.
Weil es React Komponenten sind
und keine Svelte Komponenten.
Mach ich ja schon. Aber in Kombination
mit ein bisschen vorgefertigten Sachen.
Es gibt vieles.
Es liegt dann
aber immer im Detail, weil irgendwelche Sachen
kacke aussehen oder nicht so funktionieren,
wie man denkt. Wie heute beispielsweise
der Stepper. Ja, bei dem ist es dann
vielleicht irgendwie
keine Ahnung, die
Kart Komponent oder so.
Ich glaube, ich mach das.
Das ist doch eh Mini. Ich brauche drei Seiten im Endeffekt.
Ja, aber es wird
da auch Sachen geben, die einem
nicht gefallen.
Zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich
persönlich beim Material UI
richtig abartig finde, ist
den Date Picker.
Nee, nicht den Date Picker.
Den Time Picker.
Der ist richtig eklig.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Äh.
Ist das irgendwo eine Demo?
Nee, das ist ein guter Time Picker hier.
Wo ich weiß, dass er hässlich aussieht.
Hier.
Alter.
Das ist so eklig. Ich hasse diesen
Time Picker, diesen Material Design Time Picker.
Das ist so abartig,
das Ding. Ich weiß nicht, wer damit
gerne Uhrzeiten pickt.
Übrigens, das ist
Moment mal, Moment mal.
Das ist jetzt ja 12. Wenn das
bis 24 geht, ist es noch viel abartiger.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man
das hier einstellen kann.
Das haben die hier in der Demo-Seite
nicht drin,
auf 24 Stunden umzustellen.
Richtig, richtig
abartig, äh.
Natürlich gibt es JQuery
immer noch. Kannst du theoretisch, ja.
Ja, für Touchen ist das ganz
nice. Das lasse ich mir noch gefallen,
aber ansonsten.
JQuery UI. Das gibt es garantiert
auch noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch einer dran entwickelt.
Naja.
Ich meine,
nur 3 Monate
alt, ne.
JQuery kriegt immer noch regelmäßige
Patches.
Hehehe.
Also,
scheint noch aktiv zu sein.
Ich meine, 50% oder so,
ne, ich glaube, es sind sogar mehr,
als 50%. Der Top Websites
auf der Welt benutzen ja
wie immer noch JQuery, also.
Das wird so schnell nicht
verschwinden.
JQuery. Leute, ich gehe ins Bett.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Macht's gut. Bis dann.
CU.